And it was a huge issue before you came along.
A huge issue in the sport and continues to be in other organizations,
particularly overseas.
I mean there's just rampant speculation about companies that literally encourage
people to take steroids.
It was always the case with pride in Japan.
That was one of the big things about pride ends in anyway,
who fought for them many times came on the podcast and literally was saying in
the contract and like capital letters,
it says we will not test you for steroids.
Like they wanted everybody to take steroids.
They,
I had friends who went to fight over there.
They told them to take steroids and move up a weight class.
So it was always an issue in the sport that this was a dirty sport air quotes.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
but since you've come along and since you guys started instituting this
incredibly strict testing,
we've seen some pretty radical changes.
We've seen some amazing fights and amazing performances and I don't think the
performance levels dropped.
In fact,
I think it escalated and elevated rather,
which is something that people were really concerned about.
But one thing that we did see is some people that you suspected of doing stuff,
their bodies radically changed.
It was really mean.
That became a meme pre Usada and post Usada.
I mean,
and there's some comedy memes out there because of it,
because people's bodies change so radically.
Yeah.
It's an interesting,
you know,
the last time I was on,
we talked about kind of the smell test,
you know,
looking at somebody and you know,
it's difficult to say definitively whether or not,
you know,
changes in bodies are due to that or not,
but you know,
you can't help but look at some of these pictures before and after you saw it.
And I think that's the case.
That's something I always struggle with.
How do you judge the success of a program?
Um,
you know,
do you judge it on numbers of positive tests?
I don't think that's necessarily the case.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not catching everybody.
Maybe there's no one to catch.
Um,
do you judge it on before and after pictures?
I don't know.
I mean that,
that could be one factor.
I like to judge it a lot.
Anecdotally.
You know,
a big part of my job is getting out and building relationships with our
fighters,
with managers,
with coaches,
and just,
you know,
chewing on the rear and,
and,
and figuring out what they're seeing and what they're hearing.
And almost universally the feedback I get from them is this is making a big
difference.
Um,
you know,
one thing I brought with me today and really the coolest piece of date I think
I've seen in any anti-doping program are some really objective measurable
statistics and the UFC anti-doping program.
You Soda,
so you saw it as the United States antidoping agency.
They're the official antidoping agency of the United States by an act of
Congress.
They're in charge of all drug testing for us Olympic sports.
Uh,
back in 2015 we made the decision to outsource the administration of our program
to Usada.
The primary reason being the independence factor.
Um,
you know,
when you look at all these other professional sports league,
some have,
you know,
better programs and others none really have any independence and the
administration,
that program.
And what that means is there's no way of telling whether or not,
um,
you know,
when an athlete is sanctioned is done for business reasons or done for
favoritism.
So in our program,
you know,
no one can say that any of the administration of our program has done for that
reason.
It's a truly independent authority.
So what you saw it did recently as they went back and they'd been in existence
since I think about 2001 on the US Olympic level.
They went back and took a look at every single doper I think for steroids.
Everyone was caught for steroids in the existence of the Usada program and took
a look at each of those athletes,
biological passports and biological markers.
And they looked at what was the most common factor for the doper versus you
know,
the non doper.
And what they determined was what stood out the most was large variance in
testosterone excretion in the urine.
And we think about it from a common sense point of view that that Kinda makes
sense.
And that someone who's using steroids at that time presents a sample.
Their testosterone excretion is probably going to be on the higher end.
And if they were to catch a doper on an off cycle,
what happens when you get off steroids is your body suppresses production of
testosterone.
So in that case you're going to see a very low excretion of testosterone.
So they looked at that and plotted it out and saw hey,
every dope or has a very large variance in testosterone excretion.
Then what they did is they took all the UFC samples and they plotted out by
quarter and actually brought a graph along with me.
And it's some really drastic,
I think,
visual evidence of the success and the impact of this program.
I don't know if you can throw that up,
take a look at it.
Um,
so what,
what year exactly did,
uh,
you sought a takeover?
Yeah.
So we can't,
you saw of came into play July of 2015 so if you saw it has been in existence
for two years.
So you see here,
um,
that first quarter,
quarter three of 2015,
a pretty decent variance there.
Um,
which means in any given test and athlete,
you know,
I was up on an average a little bit at 30.
I'm a little,
you know,
in the mid twenties.
And then look at,
as you plot out that graph,
uh,
that variance becomes smaller and smaller and smaller and more in the medium
range as it gets out to,
you know,
a quarter three of 2017.
That's very interesting.
You don't,
you don't,
this is,
you don't usually see statistics.
This is the first I've been involved in anti-doping world since 2002 and I can
unequipped equivocally say that this is the strongest visual,
objective,
measurable evidence of success of a program that I've ever seen.
Well,
one of the things that's so fascinating about this,
and um,
this,
this goes to this coast credit to the UFC 100% is that they decided to do
something about this.
They didn't have to,
it wasn't like someone coming after them because,
uh,
you know,
so many people had been caught and someone said,
hey,
we're going to put a program on you guys to make sure you're not doping.
Or the UFC said,
we've got to clean this up.
And there's,
there's only one way.
The one way is to go with the very best testing possible and the most rigorous,
the most check checkin everywhere you go,
we're going to give you random test,
six o'clock in the morning,
knock on your door,
like the whole,
the whole full gamut of tests and the results have been pretty amazing.
And that alones that speaks volumes when you see this size of the variance
between the,
uh,
the test when you guys first started versus now.